you get a piece of a company and then
they become the Apple yeah
Apple apparently has a more than a
trillion dollars now I know that meant
insane that's kind of dangerous anybody
to have that kind of influence though
with these phones and [ __ ] it's like
that's pretty pretty dangerous yeah I I
kind of trust them with data though I
feel like even with their China deal
yeah well Google has a weird China deal
too well they also have secret servers
in North Korean oh yeah I mean they just
have servers set up in all these other
countries it all of trust any of them
what are they doing in North Korea
I don't know it's all dick pics yeah I
mean his Rovers full of dick I think
there's all kinds of networks that have
been going on for years that
are involved in [ __ ] I think like I was
I'd tell my friends or my drummer
specifically I talked to you but I was
like man I think I like I'm not a rich
guy
but like I think that there's a point of
money that I would I would like to know
the threshold in which you get past that
and then like the Saudis and then all
the cut all these people start coming
and wanting a part of you and then you
start selling your soul like whatever
that is if it's five million bucks
I just got stay right there that would
be a bit richer than that and once you
have influence I think it's it becomes a
scary world so I like I think there's a
lot of concern early people wonder
whether or not someone's bit like I've
been accused of being approached like
that I'm a CIA acid or that I here's a
big I think that's really the flat earth
Oh Flat Earth people they think that
I've been approached to talk about the
earth being round to be a round earth
shell Jamie started selling teas around
Earth shield James got round earth shell
t-shirts that he sells at young Jamie
calm man I mean around or the she'll
chill is like saying like you know that
the reptilian people went to you to be a
human shield Oh someone told me that
someone told me that they believe that
there's reptilians underneath the earth
and that they have carlier they've
carved tunnels through the ground with
laser beams and they have like a network
of tunnels they use they travel amongst
us waiting for their time to expose
themselves people believe like you see
someone like say if you live in an
apartment building and you try by dudes
house got a fat house you go Wow
fad house I wonder wonder who he knows
when if he's like he's in with the the
mob or maybe he's deep with the
Democrats or maybe he's the bankers or
who's Guzzi who does he know because you
always think of like someone like being
like at a level where you're you're you
like they sit you in a room and they
give you some communications that you're
not supposed to expose to the rest of
the world right well I mean there is
again what I would I would say about the
threshold of money there is a point and
you know it's there
in which in I mean Google started with a
couple dudes right we're like we got
this idea there was before that there
was a thing called web crawler that was
kind of the first experience of me of a
search engine that I never experienced
well there was Netscape Navigator was a
wasn't that first browser yeah there was
a mosaic and Netscape Navigator but
there was a way to search that was web
caller Lycos well came later
Lykos what yahoo came later and but yeah
there was web crawler then Yahoo and
like us and then Google just over yeah
yeah thing passed calm still they're
thinking that's so they're yeah still
there but uh but like you know you got a
look couple dudes in an office hey we
got a web search and we're all of a
sudden there they've got Khan I mean
Amazon as CIA contracts that's that's
known because they use their servers to
do things you got you got a look Amazon
has like super super secure servers but
they still been hacked they're as secure
as anyone elses yeah they just have once
you make that I think it's the maybe
it's five hundred million there's got to
be a mark yeah there's a no which in
which people start approaching you and
saying hey man you've got too much
influence would you like to join our
group and we'll support you and it'll
make a billion yeah